man who's been covering Denver sports
with the Denver Post since 1983 the year
John Elway was drafted his column
Broncos need to send John Elway to
showers and hire Peyton Manning his
director of football operations
certainly caught my eye Marc Isla here
on the Rich Eisen show how are you mark
I'm good rich how you doing man I'm
doing fine that is quite the headline
and quite the column you wrote Marc why
do you feel this way well at the risk of
sounding like I'm going to deliver a
football eulogy let me say that John
Elway has his name on ribeye steaks at
his restaurant in the south and he has
his name on SUVs that car dealerships in
this town he's not like you said he's
been here since 1983 every Super Bowl
championship nearly every piece of
success the Broncos have had since 1983
can be tied directly to John Elway he's
not only the face of the Denver Broncos
he's the face of Denver Colorado
he's the Duke of Denver it's been he got
here in his early 20s out of Stanford he
turns 60 next year I mean who does that
anywhere in sports we're talking an
entire generation that he defines the
Broncos in this town it's been a great
run with this over I the man is fresh
out of ideas and it happens it happens
to the best of them he eventually had to
retire as a quarterback and he's not
doing the job as general manager anymore
and and for your national audience
that's not even that crazy of notion
here in Denver Colorado
anymore the reaction to my column today
within the city
now we're talking social media and as
you well know social media is usually
louder and more passionate than
absolutely accurate and if 85 percent in
my corner I mean it's not if I'd written
this three years ago it would have been
a hundred and seven percent against me
but
the fact is that public opinion has
soured and obviously what's happened
over the last couple of years has he
what like what what part of his fastball
do you think might not be as fast
anymore
mark he just had I mean the number one
job of a general manager is to in my
opinion is to restock your team build
your team through the NFL Draft and he
has been very poor at that I can throw
out any number of ideas from 2013 to
2015
now that's the time when the Broncos are
at the top of the heap so they're
drafting at the back end of every single
round so I get you on that way that
there are three Jaffe's 2013 to 2015
those players right now are in their
late mid to late 20s space if their
starters they should be in their prime
in those three drafts the Broncos have
one player on the current roster total
player and if that creates a great big
hole in your roster in it not only a
great big hole it creates many many
holes and that's why the Broncos are 18
and 32 in their last 50 games the Denver
Post Marcus lahir on the Rich Eisen show
and then so let's get to the second part
of your of your of your fix if you will
sending in John Elway to the showers or
having him leave in his leadership role
and putting Peyton Manning in do you
think he would do something like that
mark I do not know I mean I wrote a book
about Peyton Manning's time in in Denver
yeah and at one point I had a chat with
with somebody that worked with him as an
actor and it was a TV director and he
said Peyton you know if you want to be
an actor after your football career you
can take Hollywood by storm and he can
basically let him know I don't wanna be
an actor I want to own the movie studio
so maybe maybe being the director of
football operations
it's not big enough job for Peyton
Manning maybe he wants to own the
Annapolis Colts or or or the king of the
world and I wouldn't put that past them
either well I guess then wouldn't if he
if this is something he would do
wouldn't it be the same issue that you
might have with Elway is somebody who's
played the game but hasn't really event
essentially put a team together being
put in in charge
Marc or you just want anything do you
just want anything I just want anything
to be done right now it's been so bad no
no no no this something has to be done
and that's not a fan reaction it's it's
it's it's I just mentioned 18 and 32
Mike Shanahan two-time Super Bowl
champion coach greatest coach in Broncos
history in his last 50 games before he
was fired he was 26 and 24 as von Miller
said after the game last night there's a
very high standard here and and it's not
easy being John Elway trying to maintain
that standard and that standard hasn't
been maintained John Lynch is done John
Lynch who who who spent time in Denver
the Niners are doing okay and John Lynch
came out of it television books so you
know so did Matt Millen that didn't work
out so well so I understand this that if
Peyton Manning were running this
operation I think he would surround
himself with great football people and
he might have a general manager under
him if John Elway is going to be
involved in this organization next year
I think he's going to get a very strong
suggestion from Joe else president of of
this organization that hey John you have
to change the people around you you have
to bring in strong football people
around you and and whether he is willing
to do that or not I don't know
last one for you mark where's drew lock
is he is he close because if he can get
out off of IR
and they just throw them out there and
if he can actually perform very well
then that might change the tenor of this
entire conversation where is he right
now he is supposed to be close to being
able to effectively practice and start
that clock ticking about whether the
Broncos decided to bring him off IR that
does sound and look promising but how
many times the joke is that last night
some of my colleagues said do you really
want to put your Lackey behind that
offensive line um but I agree drew lock
needs to get snaps and he needs to get
starts this week well I mean he one
would think he's a little bit more
mobile and Flacco I mean that that's
part of the issue too right I mean so
you got to see what you got I mean
certainly if if if Elway is potentially
in a final throw situation which is I
guess my last question for you is I know
you're you you have your set of eyes and
you have your years of of seeing this
franchise and knowing what the fan base
expects do you think Joe Ellis would be
willing to make a maneuver like the one
that you put at the top of your column
here mark I think he would be willing to
consider it
III definitely think that and and and I
think you will have to consider it if
this team ends up four and twelve five
and eleven six and ten and yet mark
thanks for the call really appreciate it
we'll chat again another time hopefully
in half down time yeah you got it thanks
guy that smart Kissel of the Denver Post
for more of the Rich Eisen show tune -
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV for free
on BR Live or download the Rich Eisen
show app